[Música]
i
para empezar les quería preguntar un par
de cositas
quería saber si creen que un libro les
puede llegar a cambiar la vida
si creen que un libro les puede cambiar
una realidad
si un libro les puedo hacer pensar
diferente
y si un libro les puede dejar una huella
mi respuesta a todas las preguntas
anteriores
hace un par de años pasé por un momento
algo difícil y lleno de dudas estudiaba
en un colegio a 130 km de mi casa
pero tenía la posibilidad de cambiarme a
otro con la misma orientación
agrotécnica qué es lo que quiero seguir
y lo que sigo y al mismo tiempo estar
más cerca de mi familia lo único que me
faltaba era el valor para hacerlo me
faltaba ese coraje
pero leí un libro y mi vida cambió
ese libro me hizo ver qué
el miedo es una excusa que todos usan
siempre
que incluso las acciones más pequeñas
tienen una interminable cadena de
consecuencias y que las cosas nunca van
a volver a ser como antes
y también aprendí a dejar de dar una
importancia
a esas tontas preocupaciones
aprendí que
muchas veces
le estaba en mi caso le estaba dando
importancia a algunas cosas que no que
no importaban
por ejemplo cuando un chico se tiene que
levantar a las 5 de la mañana para ir al
colegio volver a las 7 de la noche
o estar toda una semana en un albergue
que viene a ser mi caso pero a pesar de
todo seguir seguir porque sabemos y
porque sé que es algo que me hace crecer
y tampoco voy a decir que me encante mi
rutina pero de ella también aprendo que
las mejores cosas nos cuestan un poco
más vivo en colonia aurora una zona
rural a 200 kilómetros de la capital
posadas
sobre la ruta número 2 que está al
margen del río uruguay
las principales o sea la mayoría de la
familia se dedica a la agricultura
familiar donde los principales cultivos
son de ananá [ __ ] tabaco y maíz también
se dedican a la ganadería y lechería
pero en menor escala
yo crecí en una familia que
siempre me diseño
que los valores y la educación son la
base de todo en una familia que
siempre trata de superarse esa es una
imagen con mis compañeros del albergue
con esa gente
que
con esas personas que crezco con esas
personas que me enseñan cantidades cosas
con
con personas que están de lunes a
viernes conmigo acá también les muestro
una imagen de lo que es colonia aurora
de lo que es la producción es una imagen
de mi colegio del año pasado por eso les
quería decir les quería contar que no
importa la plataforma del libro no
importa si es en físico o si es en
digital no importa el lugar que estés
yo soy lectora
y no tengo internet las 24 horas del día
no tengo una biblioteca pública a lado
de mi casa estoy toda una semana en un
colegio y no tengo mucho tiempo libre un
libro siempre te puede cambiar puede ser
que te cambie durante un tiempo puede
ser que te cambie porque lo hayas leído
en un momento determinado puede ser que
ese libro te haya
que ese libro te va a pensar diferente
te haga cambiar de perspectivas
y para encontrar a ese libro muchas
veces no basta con solo con sólo leer
tenemos que leer con nuestros ojos con
nuestras manos con esa voz tan personal
que resuene en cada lectura que
realizamos como no nombrar a mi
profesora de lengua que hace un tiempo
me dijo que la lectura fomenta la
educación y la educación mata la
ignorancia
por eso
gracias
y por eso una vez que conozcan la
lectura pueden rechazarla o seguir
seguir buscando a ese libro seguir
cambiando y seguir mejorando haciendo
que un libro nos acompañe nos ilumine y
nos deja una huella eso es todo
[Aplausos]
[Música]